that guy's out of them that's done this
before my life so you just follow your
heart when you got yeah probably about
you over flip and see they put already
tried without anything and they define
[ __ ] up probably means like pretty much
working computer whoa that works great
there's a moon in the Sun baby yeah I'm
trying to see it thank you I stack it
enough layers
sounds like blood-red things I've never
actually tried to look at a nycos before
like the first time I had doubled over
again an outside to Perez is cool
come in here and there's a red whoa
that's difficult
you can't you can kind of fit Oh move it
over one more time much oh damn why is
it red what everyone's freaked out about
laughter yeah
awesome setting for the moon ah
everything's backwards we'll have any
assessment I wish you would subscribe to
BAM Neko channel dude I wish that the
Sun would pass in front of the moon no I
don't want that it has be bad they can't
see oh [ __ ]
have the blood of a wolf dinner in me to
be part wolf
I know Wow oh you want to go out into
the street in slip it then you know [ __ ]
it where it tasted from you you'd be so
good that's I got us a snack so it's
coming right now
wait what you get pieces cool sorry guys
that's not about everything with it
they're like we had pista last night
person to have a night before that they
do it every day for pizza every day kind
of guys feel this hair yeah this guy is
pizza oh I can eat these ons before I
can you Kenya Kenya and then our coolest
asatyam
Canyon what skateboarder not really have
you tried yeah here we go put this
outside ready by the way let me hear how
the funny business you like this because
it's just I'm trying to figure out our
36 inch pizza oh my god that's stuck now
I gotta go cook it when it stops like
that you wanted cuz then you got a big
door dude ah
bring on the floor I see huh Gannett
right there i side of the floor
thank you all right
by the way I joined Moses now I never
done it you're second at that time I
wouldn't refer to as induced I didn't do
that that was like the peace delivery
guard raid on a Ninja Turtles movie back
in the city wow that's like the size of
a table once you look in this corner
there's okay so there's obviously some
perks to running a YouTube channel that
revolves around Tech which is companies
are like hey guys we have high tech
stuff we want you guys to test it out
and use it and see if it is indeed good
for the types of videos and content you
make kind of in hopes that other people
see this footage and learn something
about it - maybe it's right for them as
well but in this lock there's something
very special there's one of the things I
requested not just this microphone but
both of these microphones these are - II
914 Sennheiser mics there's a reason I
got - these are some very very high
quality condenser microphones they're
very versatile microphone
anything from recording like a guitar an
acoustic guitar to going out into nature
and getting giant stereo field
recordings of environments or spaces so
they can be used anywhere and the reason
I have two is so we can utilize that
stereo effect to take these two things
and point them outwards like that and
get basically a sonic space and capture
that for cool ambient sounds or
environment noises etc you can bring
them into a studio and instead of
pointing them out like this you can take
them and put them like this at a single
small object to get a stereo effect of
something that happening at this size as
well okay
I hate to break it to you but these are
not microphones their flashlights I'm
sorry
Oh a flashlight this is the flashlight
they gave us hold on actually seriously
though this is really my jam right now
whoo these are fancy I like these a lot
these microphones they are condenser
microphones but they also have these
things called cardioid shapes which
basically inside the microphone they
listen to sounds and accept and reject
sounds depending on which angle they're
hitting it cardioids and super cardioid
so the shape of the sound that they
receive kind of bows outward from the
front of them and
kind of reject sounds from side and from
the back a little bit that's how the
directional aspect of these work we have
two stereo mics pointing like this we're
obviously getting a lot here but as we
start to widen them you start to
actually widen this stereo effect
because you start capturing sound that
normally would be outside their natural
range so easy example you're recording
an action scene you want to get cool
reloading sounds you have your airsoft
gun what you can start doing is actually
putting them in the middle like this
things like kind of what they call an X
Y configuration here you start to get
very very different sonic effects
depending on how you angle these
microphones towards or away from your
scene or object forever
so we'll see what happens here in a bit
don't worry it's a great day I have
stuff about cleaning up while cooking if
there's nothing that's better than
finishing your meal and being done
cooking with it and then like having a
clean kitchen while you eat at the same
time cleaning up after you eat that's
the worst part about using a mirror on
the set the coolest thing you can do
while okay is clean so I got a little
story for you guys that one ain't about
bacon in baking moment we first moved
out to LA you're a super for it may just
shot like a low-budget monster movie
there's a like a wholesale place on the
street called Smart & final and we go
shopping there and I really like bacon
and I can really really afford you like
the bacon ends like I just like the
trimmings where you get a whole big pack
on four bucks
the baby's bidding giant like both fat
and bacon at like 30 dollars it look is
huge like back and ravage slab a bacon I
told myself like when I can buy this
pack is like giant attack of bacon for
30 bucks I've made like when I can put
this with my I'm Vic and I'm going to
have made it and the first time we ever
bought one those patches a table so we
shower at the meals on collaboration
sup nerds so that marks the first time I
achieved one of my mated check marks
with you guys about that
I've optimal moment I said when I can
build my own conceit that will play the
newest games at at least 30 frames but I
made it and I called you up on the phone
when I was building that piece and ask
you what kind of PC I should build until
you two were a part of my benchmark now
you did it
let's quit in it we made it alright I'm
out of here so we're looking at the
Eclipse through this in detail it works
pretty well you could see a really cool
little crescent shape yeah it works
really well but the thing is I was
reading online last night about every
burying their eyeballs and people are
like no those in details aren't made for
blocking I RUV you've been getting
blasted with UV light you don't even
know it is it like a late offset
blindness like 10 years later like you
get stressed out and we have crescent
forms when you're hiding huh why
shouldn't watch that Eclipse I did a
little more research for what I see nd
filters generally block everything
across the spectrum not quite evenly but
you stack it you know a bunch of times
everything gets cut down I don't know I
remember you showed me a plastic garbage
bag yeah that's black yep and you take
the infrared camera it was clear
yeah right through you see right through
it so let's find out it's infrared light
can shine through this thing you look
like your floor camera yeah it's the
FLIR one information amaura there's near
infrared which is like what like
security cameras and stuff are that like
see at nighttime but this is like actual
inference so this is like a sheet so
this is a plastic garbage bag see a hot
Nick here I'm gonna raise this black
garbage bag and I can still see a hot
Nick right dip it down today what you
can yeah how many fingers I'm holding up
three fingers damn it oldest triggers
your holy up four fingers now you're
only up to okay yeah that's right power
of x-ray vision a find out of all kinds
of wine
all right there's Knicks one layer
that's just one layer though yeah
shutting it down close due to kept
anything that is anything really yep if
I even just doubled up one you're almost
gone a little more time what you did
with one poor I mean I already can't see
them can't turn it off
cool so don't let some infrared through
what seems that you submitted about the
same amount as regular light yeah
there's no way yeah yeah I'm feeling
more confident about our Irish is not
dying I feel better than ever
what do you mean better than ever I've
just been like seeing weird things
hey it has a longer of my life but it's
important it the dress 14 and a half
hours will this up on this carbon I got
some wacky looking footage here can't
even talk right now
well yes I left yesterday at noon stayed
in Vegas for like for six hours sleeping
woke up this morning drove straight back
little old news at this point but I went
to see the Eclipse I didn't fly and stay
in the hotels and fancy things we drove
there with no plan it was really intense
I do have something to show for my
efforts in my journey here I'm not
really sure how it turned out I really
really really want to see what's on this
car
I don't have any there's no promises
here I really don't know what I was
capturing either because at a certain
point when things started going down I
was just like whatever and like I
stopped worrying about filming and I
just started like enjoying it so we
ended up going through Wyoming to
Jackson Wyoming I decided to just film
it with like everything stopped down as
much as I could with the variable nd
because I was having serious like
swearing issues for some reason so it's
going to be very abstracted I think
because I film some of these at like 8
frames per second so they like you could
see the motion happening oh yeah there
you go you can see moving
so the thing is like the Sun is moving
more behind the moon than the moon is
moving in front of the Sun because
that's watch that you can see it rising
a little bit there you know yeah oh here
so then this is the type of flaring I'm
talking about you know we because we did
I noticed though this is the flaring I'm
talking about so I took the NZ off and
just went full bright and it gives you
can see like normally when you aim the
camera at the Sun you see like normal
lens flare but like Claire yeah you get
these special Eclipse players because
it's happening like Tonioli I filmed
this also at experience for a second - I
think is so you can see stuff keep
scooting by super fast
ok I know because I hope I hope it
didn't - so is this clip I think [ __ ] is
probably worth just watching you just
came to see the whole thing happened
right there and so if you can see you
can see how bright it still is I'm
literally aiming the camera into the Sun
and the sky is black that's how much how
much I have to stop down that nuts left
and there you go and that's what happens
my brain rope when this happened and I
was looking at the camera because the
eclipse was happening I look up and it's
like holy [ __ ]
and I looked down at the camera and I
see what I've been trained to see it as
a camera and then my brain glitched out
just hit some buttons on the camera
while looking at it and I started kept
spilling the equipment but my brain
wasn't working anymore and so the whole
shot of the actual clip is out of focus
time just like because between what this
whole like this movie that looks dope
out of focus and I believe hit the
camera I like I walk away without even
checking the focus on whoa whoa and I
later on I realize like why this is
totally a totally out of focus and like
oh man I'm an idiot
and so I get the other side to in focus
this stuff was pretty cool though I
think it's just like these bizarre
flares it's flaring artifacts that were
happening
those clipz clipz clipz clipz
[Music]